Aggarwal: WYSA's an emotional
resilience tool for mental health.
People talk to WYSA when they don't want
to talk to another human being.
Originally, what we were trying to do
was detect depression using sensidata
from a phone.
We found that very few people had actually
been able to access help,
but many of them had been using
the chat bot and had found it helpful,
and that's when the idea
of WYSA came about.
Detection isn't enough.
You have to actually help people.
Selby: I've been using WYSA
with my patients
for two, maybe two and a half years now.
WYSA really helps people to reflect
and learn more about themselves,
their own well-being, and the things they
can do to strengthen their well-being.
Initially,
there's this chat-based function
that allows you to be really reflective
in quite a safe and secure way,
'cause you know it's anonymous
and you know there's no judgment, but
then it also offers modules and support.
We had a mum and a young girl
who came to see us
who were both quite anxious.
Everyday things would start
a bit of a worry
and it was starting to feel
really overwhelming for them.
We got them both to use WYSA.
The young girl learned a lot about things
to help her feel less anxious.
So she got in the habit
of sitting in her seat,
having maybe 30 seconds, a minute
mindfulness moment
before she'd give a class presentation,
and that really helped her.
And mum particularly noticed a massive
improvement.
Colleagues at work were commenting
on how much more relaxed she was.
Her life had completely changed
and she felt much more able
to do things with her daughter
and really achieve what she wanted to do.
Technology can be a huge enabler
in helping people understand
that you can support
your own mental health,
and technology will change the way
we look after ourselves.
Aggarwal: We're trying to make the world
more mentally resilient.
Technology's always been seen
as a part of the problem,
and now we want to make it the solution.